[Music]
Barbie and can maybe children's toys but
even adults are in love with these
iconic dolls when love turns into
obsession some people go to great
lengths to recreate Barbie and Ken's
looks and there's no limits to how far
some people will go to look like they're
made of plastic if you're new to our
channel don't forget to hit the
subscribe button and give this video a
big thumbs up because today we'll be
showing you 10 real-life Barbie and
Kendall's Roderigo Alva's flight
attendant Rodrigo Alves has spent more
than five hundred thousand dollars to
look exactly like 10 gives undergone a
band plant hair transplants jaw
reconstruction a Brazilian butt lift
liposuction cap shaping and multiple
nose jobs his nose has been
reconstructed so many times that Rodrigo
now says he has trouble breathing less
that hasn't stopped his goal of becoming
what he likes to call himself at the
human Kendall Carey miles
self-proclaimed Barbie girl Carrie miles
has spent over 125 thousand dollars over
the past few years to transform herself
into a real-life doll to maintain her
Barbie looks she receives regular lip
fillers botox hair extensions teeth
whitening and splurges on makeup and
beauty products she has even set aside
money for her young daughter just in
case she grows up and wants to get
plastic surgery to look like a Barbie
doll - Jennifer Pamplona
when Jennifer Pamplona met her boyfriend
social Santa Venice also known as the
human Ken doll he had dreams of turning
her into his real-life Barbie in 2015
Celso died after battling cancer and
Jennifer honored his wishes by going
under the knife to transform herself
into a Barbie doll Jennifer has now had
liposuction breast implants fat
injections in her butt and thighs cheek
and lip fillers and a nose job in total
she has spent over $100,000 but it was a
small price to pay
she says the plastic surgery has helped
her cope with celso's death Hennig
Gregory Hannah Gregory has been given
the title of Britain's first human
Barbie and she's more than happy to
accept the honor her doll-like
appearance includes a 22 inch waist
large doe eyes and a predominantly pink
wardrobe inspired by the doll Hanna says
she loves dressing like Barbie and she
encourages others to do the same
Mauricio gaudi when it comes to being
obsessed
with Ken Mauricio Gaudi definitely takes
the cake growing up in Brazil he envied
girls who were able to play with Barbie
and Ken dolls but he was never able to
join in for fear of being teased as he
got older he decided instead of playing
with Ken
he'll just become Ken instead at the age
of 17 he had a nose job in fillers in
his face he has since undergone nine
procedures in total including chest and
arm implants and four nose jobs Heidi
Montag while appearing on MTV's the
hills Heidi Montag decided to spend her
hard-earned money on multiple plastic
surgery procedures she had ten surgeries
in one day including breast implants but
augmentation a brow lift a nose job and
liposuction when her mother saw her new
look for the first time she said it
sounds to me like you want to look like
Barbie Heidi's eyes lit up she had a
huge smile on her face and she gleefully
replied I do want to look like Barbie
mission accomplished Quenton dejar
quentin de haar was so inspired by Ken's
good looks and his billionaire lifestyle
and he decided to transform himself into
a real-life Ken doll at the age of 18 he
had his first nose job and the following
year she received Botox injections in
his face he has since spent over
$100,000 on plastic surgery procedures
including four nose jobs and ear pinning
surgery he finally felt like he was
morphing into Ken but he was missing one
thing a woman who looked just like
Barbie he ended up finding her and her
name was Anastasia rhaskos Anastasia
bresca when Quentin died Harmon
Anastasia arrests cos at a boat party in
saint-tropez it was love at first sight
they spent the entire night talking
about how much they loved Barbie and Ken
and they discussed all of their plastic
surgery goals Anastasia has spent over a
hundred and sixty thousand dollars on
various procedures including a breast
augmentation to take her from a 32 C to
a 32 E she and Quentin even had plans to
legally change the names to Barbie and
Ken but that all changed when Quentin
fell out of love and dumped honest Asia
after she dyed her hair black how rude
pixee fox when glamour model pixie Fox
decided she wanted to look like Barbie
she completely changed her entire body
she increased her bust size to a 30 J
and had six ribs removed to get a waist
as Tiny as bar
in total she spent 125 thousand dollars
on plastic surgery procedures but there
was still one thing missing from her
life her real-life Ken but that all
changed when she met Justin jedlica
Justin jedlica at the age of 18 Justin
jedlica became addicted to looking like
Ken
he has spent over a hundred and seventy
thousand dollars on three hundred and
forty plastic surgery procedures
including cheek shoulder back bicep and
butt implants as well as five nose jobs
his life was absolutely perfect his
dream of becoming Ken was finally
happening and he was happy and in love
with his husband but after he and his
partner divorced he decided to put his
love life on the backburner
he and pixee fox' moved in together and
they now encouraged each other to get
more plastic surgery they needed booked
a few procedures at the same time so
they can go through the recovery process
together these two are like a match made
in Barbie doll heaven which of these
real-life Barbie and Ken doll shocked
you the most react in the comments
section down below and don't forget to
give this video a big thumbs up
you
[Music]